welcome calculator fanciers to number
files series of unboxing videos - Matt
Parker and I will be looking at these
three fantastic specimens for you today
okay so we'll start with the Morrisons
desktop calculator those of you not from
the UK morrison's is a particularly
classy shop over here think kind of
Herod's 2 pounds is not a bad amount of
money now what I like about this is
before you're committing to that kind of
investment because it's in a transparent
Lister pack and because it's reasonably
flexible you can actually turn it on
while it's in there and you can test it
in the shop
7 times 7 make sure we get 49 and you
kind of know what you're getting in 4
before you buy it we however have
shelled out both of those pounds so we
will open it up and see what we're
actually dealing with now that blister
pack is surprisingly easy to cut through
here we go as you can see I am very
safely cutting towards my body at all
times so I can keep a closer eye on the
blade
we now pop this open there we are oh
okay so first thing out is instruction
booklet which is in case you're
unfamiliar with the concept of numbers
being represented by digits we'll leave
that for later reference
should we get confused and there is no
other real information on the packet
again it tells you to not put it in the
bin because it is a calculator and it's
very difficult to use in a bin in fact
that is repeated on the leaflet over
there and marcin's do claim that they
are here to help I'm sure if we do ring
their helpline which they give you here
if we have any calculation or
mathematical inquiries about the
calculator they should be able to help
us out okay so we'll get it out of its
packet there we are
and yes as you can see it looks
alarmingly similar to what it did inside
the packet I can't there's two tiny
screws on the back but it's all the
powers that should be fine for the
display it's pretty good we can get one
two three four five six seven eight nine
eight we can get eight digits it can do
all the four major functions they can
add subtract multiply and divide it's
also got a square root which is very
interesting in fact we'll take the
square root for a spin we'll put in two
square root and that looks pretty
accurate to me and then just as a test
we'll multiply that by the square root
of two
and the answer is one point nine nine
nine nine nine nine eight okay that's a
little bit out about we can try a
classic one okay one divided by zero
equals error again
okay no problem okay so accuracy is not
brilliant functions are perfectly
possible if we cover up the screen there
it's got a decent battery life so should
it become temporarily overcast you can
continue calculating and in terms of
holding in the hand it's not great it's
a bit awkward to hold to be asked but
then again as you can see they very
explicitly say put it on top of a desk
so we can't take too many points off for
that and on a desk I think that works
quite nicely the scores for the
Morrisons desktop calculator the display
I've given it five big but not enough
digits functionality five accuracy three
can't do root two in terms of ergonomics
I've given it a four its overall cred a
two you wouldn't want to be seen on the
street using this one and for durability
survive the fall quite well I give it a
6 as a total of 25 which is an average
score of 4 point 1 6 reoccurring okay so
up next we have the WH Smith scientific
calculator for using while doing science
they make a few hidden claims on the
side here that there is a 10 digit
display which we're the judges off that
is battery-powered and there's got a
hundred and thirty six functions it's
quite impressive and on the back here
they just basically list not all 136
functions but a decent number of them
and a life-size one-to-one scale of the
screen showing everything at once so I
guess if you actually see that your
calculator has crashed oh and again this
one is not for doing calculations in a
bin should you accidentally over cut the
problem is you will no longer be able to
keep your Pat your calculator in its
original packet so please be very
careful when you open this to get a kind
of hinging effect so you can return the
calculator here for display purposes
afterwards oh as always an instruction
booklet and this is substantially more
than the Morrisons look at this before
starting calculations so we have
important warnings to use before you
even start you know what lets you know
let's be Mavericks and just dive
straight in without reading any of that
so oh it's got a case should your
calculator be at risk of splashes you
can slide this from only one of the two
directions and that is not indicated
anywhere on the packet so little bit
confusing and it does click into place
very nice and should you need to eject
it there is a thumb bit at the bottom
there very very useful accuracy wise we
can check the square root test so 2
square root x 2 square root equals 2
much better
so square roots perfectly accurate now
we have trigonometry interesting test
for trigonal functions to see how small
an angle you can still calculate the
sine of and so we will switch this into
radians now we're in radians we will
take the sine of a very small angle and
if we do a sine of s a point 1
the answer this is the small angle
approximation should be about the same
number that it gives me about point one
but slightly different if I do a smaller
angle so clear that point oh one sign I
get again closer to what I started with
and the point where it can no longer
tell the difference between an angle and
the sine of the angle gives you a test
of how accurate is trigonometry neurs so
it can do 0.01 0.001
okay that's still slightly different and
then point 0:01 slightly different point
oh one that's four zeros and a one and
it's exactly the same okay so at this
point it can't tell the difference
between the angle and the sine of the
angle so as far as cameras are concerned
getting to ten to the minus four and
still being able to tell the difference
and not being able to attend to the
minus five is average to good I mean
it's all right there I wouldn't write a
song about it okay so I mean there are
loads of other functions here but I I
think we're just now instead of testing
how accurate they are because I think
the trigonometry
we will see how it handles errors so
we'll put in a negative number we'll put
in negative five whereas my negative
take the square root of that error error
and zero cool and we'll try one divided
by zero and that's again error and zero
and we'll see if it does the correct
order of operation so I'm going to do
five plus two times five if it does it
correctly we should get 15 if it doesn't
wrong we'll get 35 and it does it
correctly we got 15 so it is doing
correct orders of operation that's very
impressive this is not a bad all-round
calculator I'm very impressed with it
has got a tiny screw there should you do
so many calculations you need to put in
a new battery scores for the WH Smith
scientific calculator for the display
I've given it a seven out of ten in
terms of functionality eight accuracy
eight economics a seven
it does fit very snugly in the hand in
terms of cred I'd give it a seven hasn't
got branding it looks pretty slick and
now in terms of durability
survive the fall pretty poorly that's a
four for a grand total of 41 an average
score of 6.83 reoccuring okay and
finally we have the cannon with the arc
design and you may think I'm showing you
the back of the box here but in fact I'm
not because the front of the box is near
the back of the box it does have a lot
more information in fact even a picture
because I guess you can't see through
the packet this is entirely opaque oh
and you see I like the other ones they
have packaged it in a kind of a cuboid
of cardboard which is quite nice it's I
guess topologically equivalent to the
2-sphere and it is able to contain
something quite nicely in r3 so I'm very
impressed with the packaging there okay
so there we are so let's open that up
nicely and then in here it appears to
okay that's not it's not a smooth slide
out that it's quite as sticking quite a
bit that's nice and that's not very good
I guess for protection and safety and
should you get any spills or splashes
maybe you can keep this so should you be
calculating in a wet environment or
maybe you're using it in the shower or a
swimming pool you can put the protective
splash layer back over it I suspect it
wouldn't be good if it's actually
submerged though however I will remove
that for now as you can see is in no way
sealed to allow easy reinsertion of the
calculator into its protective cover and
we are also given here we go instruction
booklet Wow this is possibly by surface
area even bigger than the instructions
we had for the WH Smith one again if
you're unfamiliar with what buttons do
and what digits are they're all over
here and then should you wish to learn a
foreign language they have lessons in
foreign languages on this side again we
have an on an on button but suspiciously
no off button in this case I think once
you start calculating they correctly
assume you're simply not going to stop
function wise we have the four standard
guys hanging out the corner here and
then we have m/s with with different
numbers of lines and crosses next to
them and some level of memory and then
this is the Greek letter mu so should
you be calculating any density
you can use Moo and should you be using
this to do calculations in an RV let's
say you're making meth you can use the
RV mode maybe this makes it more
shock-resistant if you switch into RV or
off-road or GT is if you're racing with
the calculator it is a bit big to be on
I'm struggling to hold that entirely in
one hand whereas if you remember the WH
Smith job look at that that's a nice
little tiny package that that fits very
snugly in there and we've got a good
reach I can go all the way across
I mean it's ambidextrous whereas this
one I mean that's I mean if I was
suddenly you know needed GT mode short
notice I really I can't reach that with
the one handed mode it would have to be
put down and then used from here but it
does have a slightly raised five which
it which is very good so if you're
calculating in the dark you know after
hours calculations you can still find
your way to the five and then you can
extrapolate where all the other buttons
are from there oh and you can see in
addition to the normal zero it's got the
double zero that's for when things are
really zero I mean this one's pretty
zero
this one's absolute zero so we'll do the
square root of 2 and load Bank Wow I
mean one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve twelve
digits that's amazing I'm surprised I
don't write that right across the top oh
they do they're just twelve twelve
digits that is an impressive display but
let's see how the equity goes multiply
that by the square root of 2 and we get
ah it's well it has put it into racing
mode which is good to see that has
you've got lots of nines which which is
a real real shame there so it arming Lee
close another test we can do to see if
it can redeem its accuracy is if we do
1/9 so we get a ninth if we now multiply
that by nine if it's really accurate
we'll get one back that's not accurate
we'll get point nine reoccurring and we
get point nine reoccurring so this this
is not good for the accuracy I mean it's
got a lot of digits that can show you
unfortunately it doesn't need to use all
of them in fact it just shows you lots
and lots of inaccurate digits I mean on
the whole
I think it's quite a nice calculator and
again it's got screws on the back should
you wish to update the battery it's
battery and solar powered as I indicated
on here solar and battery that's so
during normal use it can be powered by
our free photons but should this be a
post nuclear winter you can continue
calculating solely on the battery so
there you are that ladies and gentlemen
is the Canon scores for the canon s120
with the arc design display 9 lots of
digits nice and big functionality only a
6 accuracy I've given it a six point
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
ergonomics a five it may be arced but
still hard to hold in terms of cred a
six you could get away with using this
in a math department and for durability
with the protective cover it handles
water very well
I'm giving it a seven for a total score
of thirty nine point nine nine nine nine
nine which is an average of six point
six six six six six five four - possibly
a seven
what did the number zero say to the
number eight nice belt
why do mathematicians confuse Halloween
and Christmas because acht 31 equals Dec
25 there are 10 types of people in the
world those who understand binary those
who don't and those who didn't expect
this joke to be in base 3